on va passer au buz du jour on va
revenir sur la hausse des prix de
l'électricité alors maintenant les
chéris allumer la lumière ça va vraiment
devenir une denrée rare ça veut dire que
je pense qu'on va être de plus en plus à
à vivre à la bougie hein c'est devenu un
truc de fou ça veut dire que
l'électricité maintenant c'est genre on
va rencontrer des gens dans la r quoi tu
as la lumière frère j'étais chez un gars
il avait la lumière frérot c'est un truc
de ouf quoi non mais sans déconner les
prix de l'électricité frère c'est un
loyer hein ça va être c'est un truc de
de malade voilà alors l'électricité va
augmenter de près de 10 % et Bruno Le
Maire donc le ministre de l'économie il
était hier soir 20H de TF1 il a affirmé
que c'était la faute de Poutine qui a
attaqué l'Ukraine et et du rassemblement
national donc c'est la faute de Poutine
et du rassemblement national
pour Bruno Le Maire voilà donc on lui a
dit pourquoi les tarifs augmentent-il
réellement parce que c'est la faute de
Poutine il a dit et du rassemblement
national voilà s'ils étaient pas là et
ben l'électricité serait beaucoup moins
cher donc voilà c'est la réponse de
Bruno Le Maire qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez déjà de cette réponse sur le
rassemblement national ce qu'on va on va
parevenenir dessus mais sur c'est la
faute du rassemblement national est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui jaces
Cardo non je suis pas du tout d'accord
sur les deux arguments c'est un peu
compliqué pour l'électricité on y
reviendra mais dans les deux cas c'est
totalement faux les prix enfin le le
prix réel de l'électricité correspond à
celui qu'il était avant la guerreant ou
donc on est revenu à peu près au même
niveau ça dire no factures elles ont pas
baisser donc il y a il y a une grosse
embrouille une grosse embrouille c'est C
de arguments c'est quoi l'embrouille
pourquoi donc c'est plus Chen
l'électricité pourquoi on augmente de 10
% parce que les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent à 1948 ils ont besoin de
savoir que c'est compliqué on a créé un
indice qui s'appelle le TfT qui est un
indice qui est mesuré au Pays-Bas mais
grosso modo ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est indexé sur les pays sur les prix
du gaz mais seulement pour partie donc
c'est là où je pense que il y a une
forme de d'hypocrisie c'est facile de
dire c'est de la faute de Poutine et de
la guerre parce que effectivement il y a
une il y a le prix du gaz gaz a augmenté
de 30 % et donc les prix de
l'électricité grâce à cet indice
néerlandais sont indexés sur ce ce
taux-l cet indice là mais ça n'est pas
tout à fait exact puisque ça ne compte
que pour 1/ers et puis d'autre part il y
a quelque chose qu'il faut que tout le
monde comprenne et qui est difficile à
comprendre c'est que nous on a une
énergie qui est propre avec l'énergie
nucléaire
avec enfin on a plein de choses et on
pourrait être autosuffisant mais ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça ils ont fermé
des centraleser
centrales si on était s'il y avait pas
de solidarité européenne on pourrait
finalement être presque autosuffisant en
en baissant un peu notre consommation
sauf que ça marche pas comme ça il y a
une solidarité avec les autres pays
d'Europe et donc une Centrale qui par
exemple fonctionne avec du gaz ou du
charbon et qui coûte beaucoup plus cher
et ben on est obligé de monter les prix
pour avoir une sorte de médiane entre
tous ces ce
mix moi j'avais rien capté aussi voilà
donc je vous dis c'est pour ça que je
lui demande je sais pas si vous avez
capté chez vous je me dis pourquoi
l'électricité augmente de 10 % et puis
il y a cette histoire de bouclier
tarifaire est-ce qu'on peut expliquer à
nos téléspectateurs ce qu'est le
bouclier tarifaire parce que moi j'ai
rien compris et ils disent que ça à
cause du rassemblement national qu'on a
pas fait le le bouclier tarifaire est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord alors sur le
bouclier tarifaire c'est vrai que le
gouvernement a imposé un bouclier qui a
fait que ça a limité cette hausse
c'estàdire que cette hausse et cet
indice partout dans les pays d'Europe
tout le monde a payé plus cher à cause
de cette montée et je me souviens plus
du du taux exact mais je crois que
c'était 10 ou 15 % voilà c'était 20 %
donc ça a limité et le gouvernement lui
enfin l'état c'estd la collectivité a
pris ce qu'il avait au-dessus d'une
certaine façon de sa poche donc ils ont
payé pour nous pour cette augmentation
voilà et ensuite il y a eu une
renégociation et je sais pas pourquoi il
dit que le rassemblement national que
c'est contre enfin que c'est de la faute
du rassemblement national probblement
parce qu'il n'ont pas été ils ont pas
ils ont pas été pour mais c'est plus
complexe que ça alors oui en fait le
bouclier tarifaire n'a même pas été n'a
pas été prop osé ni au vote à l'assemblé
dans aucun des dans aucune des deux
Chambres du Parlement mais en plus c'est
absolument faux parce que les
républicains et la République en marche
peuvent faire une majorité ensemble sur
ce texte et les républain avent annoncé
qu'il voter de nouveau le bouer T même
s' avit pas les VO du R ABAC AC lui tu
VO pas
n'importe euré qui lancéo ex fa argument
ce que dit Bruno le c'est que ils ont
uvré en coulisse et que ça a été une
manœuvre pour que le vote n'est pas lieu
oui oui ou oui oui bon alors on
va ou en fait l'état de l'argent et donc
ils avaient retiré une taxe qui
s'appelle la taxe intérieure de
consommation finale voilà et là il a
remett parce que Bruno lomer dit à la
dette et ça rapporte 6 milliards d'euros
donc pour trouver ces 6 milliards
d'euros ils remettent cette taxe plus
laette taxe voà 10% d'ation qu demain tu
manges un paquet de biscuit dans dans la
lumière frère tu milliardaire non mais
ça devent n'importe quoi les gars tu
peux plus acheter là à partir de demain
on va refaire les les Français en colère
je vous le dis parce qu'il faut que ça
bouge on a vu les agriculteurs aussi on
va faire un gros plateau aussi demain
là-dessus parce que c'est c'est
n'importe quoi et et alors regardez
Bruno Lemer ce qu'il est en train de
nous dire aussi c'est que si on avait
pas idé l'Ukraine et bien on aurait eu
de l'électricité en fait c'est à cause
de Poutine l'électricité aurait été
moins cher c'est ce qui est en train de
dire donc pour ça que je vous pose la
question c'est fou on devrait pas poser
cette question on vous la pose la France
a-elle raison d'aider l'Ukraine puis que
c'est ce qui ce qui l'insinue en fait
l'insinue qu'on aurait peut-être pas dû
aider l'raine risqu dire ça parce que
retour les
gens regardez ce qu'il dit regardez ce
qu'il dit monter des extrêmes de
l'extrême droite pour être précis
partout en Europe c'est les Vox en
Espagne c'est la FD en Allemagne c'est
le rassemblement national en France mais
je voudrais juste rappeler que face à
cette montée des extrêmes il y a une
seule altitude le courage y compris le
courage d'annoncer des décision
difficile comme ce que je viens de faire
sur le tarif de l'électricité
permettez-moi de rappeler au passage que
si les prix deélectricité ont flambé
c'est parce que Vladimir Poutine l'ami
de Madame Le Pen a attaqué l'Ukraine et
a fait flamber les prix d'électricité et
du gaz ils en sont directement
responsables à peu près au même Nive
alors il n'a parlé que du rassemblement
national c'est vrai qu' on lui demande
pourquoi l'électricité augmente et c'est
vrai que là j'aii contre BR en plus qui
est plutôt
sy c'est pas ça c'est là il est déjà en
campagne donc là on demande pas des gars
en campagne je vous dis on s'en fout de
gars en campagne actuellement surtout
sur les européennes on s'en fout total
je vous le dis on s'en fout total ce
qu'on veut savoir c'est pourquoi on
narrive pas à avoir de lumière et queant
avoir la lumière ça va nous coûter je
sais pas combien d'argent déjà qu'il y a
des Français qui arrivent pas à s'en
sortir le 10 du mois et les mecs qui
vont au J pour être en campagne pour
parler du rassemblement national les
Français ils en ont rien à qu'on
leur parle du rassemblement national
dans d'une interview comme ça je vous le
dis ils son tape total la seule chose
qu'il veulent savoir c'est pourquoi on a
on on on a des prix de l'électricité qui
pourrait être les mêmes puisque comme
vous l'avez dit les prix sont les mêmes
qu'avant la guerre et que les prix vont
augmenter c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
gens qui vont faire du profit on s avec
mais les sens avec he VO non mais des
gens qui vont faire juste une chose à ce
propos cyil ce qui est étonnant c'est
que Bruno Leem j'ai regardé ses propos
il y a 2 ans le système que je viens de
décrire il avait décrit lui-même comme
étant un système ubuesque et injuste
pour les français puisque notre
production d'électricité ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que on est capable de
produire à moins cher que ce qu'on paye
en réalité la question que j'aurais aimé
même poser c'est c'est c'est parce que
en fait c'est lui qui me fait poser
cette question sur l'Ukraine c'est même
pas ça c'est a-t-on les moyens à la
limite de d'aider l'Ukraine c'est ça
qu'il est en train de dire parce est en
train de N dire qu'on a pas les moyens
s'il vous plaît vous avez des petites
pcartes oui non est-ce qu'on
alors non non riment je sais que toi tu
es non non mais dis dis moi j'ai pas les
moyens personnement moi j'ai pas les
moyens moi moi bizarrement maintenant
j'ai les moyens parce que je fais touche
pas mon poste mais il y a plein de gens
qui ont pas les moyens 10 %
d'électricité en trop la la bouffe qui a
qui a augmenté aussi tu payes aussi une
TVA qui qui est dessus qui est qui est
pas normal l'essence parce que vous
parlez beaucoup deélectricité mais
l'essence c'est pareil le prix du baril
il est redevenu à peu près normal et
pourtant on continue à payer un 80
l'essence alors que on devrait pas la
payer ce prix là vous mettez le gaz
parce que le gaz il est il est indexé
sur l'électricité parce que vous parlez
deélectricité mais celui qui dit ok je
peay pas beaucoup d'élericité mais mais
il faut chauffer donc le gaz c'est
pareil sur sur sur la question que je
t'ai posé parce que il nous dit que
c'est voilà c'est c'est c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il dit voilà c'est moi
j'ai plein de conflits alors à ce
moment-là parce que c'est encore une
fois je je mets non les gens vont dire
il a pas de cœur c'est un
regarde il veut pas aider l'Ukraine moi
je veux bien aider l'Ukraine à condition
que les Français ne soient pas touché je
veux bien aller aider partout les gens
mais il faut pas que ça ça touche la vie
des Français en fait en fait ça va
toucher la vie des Français parit oui
parce fait fait att attends il va
m'exliquer je suiseux
pourquoi on défend pourquoi on défend
l'Ukraine C'est ça la vraie question
pourquoi ça pas touché
la pourquoi ça pour répond à ce
dis par que tu m'as coupé parce que tu
m'as
dit par nexliques pas pourquoi on on est
l'Ukraine on est l'Ukraine parce que on
on défend nos valeurs on défend les
valeurs occidentales on défend notre
liberté je veux bien défendre ma liberté
on pas le Cho veux bienfendre pas le
choix défendre il a dit qu'onait pas les
moy je veux bien défendre ma liberté je
veux bien aller aider les alliés les
alliés qui sont partis en Ukraine moi
aussi je me dis ils nous ont aidé et
peut-être qu'ils nous aideront plus tard
je veux bien mais quand tu dis que ça
n'a pas changé la vie des français on
devait Poutine en 3 semaines il devait
être assoifffé asséché c'est fini en 3
semaines terminer rideau et les Russes
ils sont
heureux r ça changé pour eux et viens
pas à moi dire que ça a pas changé la
vie des Français parce que moi quand je
fais mes courses je vois de 180 € d'un
panier de 180 € 150 € je suis pass 240
d'un plein d'essence à 70 € je suis
passé à 100 € gagne pas la guerre
qu'estce qui
passe fois pire que ce qui passe
mainé Guer dans le monde a 11 pays en
guerre plein de pays Ener ce
M pas les 11 pays pourquoi pourquoi on
les a pas pay le problème il est là
c'est ça nous touche pas c'est qu'on
s'en fout Mo je all aider tout le monde
mais quand je vois vous me parlez de SDF
des des députés qui vont dormir sous
destentees quand je vois que j'ai des
j'ai des j'ai des SDF 300000 SDF vous
allez me parler de démagogie quand je
vois les gens ils arrivent pas à finir
leur fin de mois nous on est bien ici on
est tranquille tu peux m'augmenter mon
électricité de 50 € si tu veux moi je
peux le faire mais il y a des gens ils
peuvent pas l'électricité l'essence la
bouffe comment tu après faut faire des
choix c'est où j'habite plus mon enfant
comme je veux ou je mange pas le midi
les étudiants c'est pareil on a des
étudiants en France qui crèvent de faim
on a des infirmières qui sont pas payés
on a des des administrations qui partent
en sucette et on me dit je vais aider le
monde
entier pourquoi tu veux pas entendre ce
que je te dis je te dis que c'est une
guerre qui nous concerne parce que c'est
notre avenir qui est en question oui Mo
j'ai pas l'impression le monde est
polarisé en deux si on nide pas
l'Ukraine le le les Russes les Chinois
se rapprochent de nous c'est comme ça
c'est et si on est l'ucraine c'est pas
pour faire plaisir c'est pas que pour
faire plaisir au
RA il sou on est oigé de penser à long
terme